but what would you say are the biggest
blocks that people have to being truly
creative and imaginative one big block
is concerns about what other people
think that's a big one I I made this
thing that I love but I think other
people would like it more if I made it
different for them
we don't know what they would like it's
a it's a really it's all in our head it
comes back to this thing of what I think
isn't good enough you know if I like it
that doesn't mean anything
that's what people think it's like just
because I like it that doesn't give it
any value like as an artist if you like
it that's all of the value that's the
success comes when you say I like this
enough for other people to see it
not other people like it so it's
successful that doesn't mean anything
because that's other people liking it is
out of your control
all that's in your control is making the
thing to the best of your ability I talk
about it usually the way I talk about it
is greatness and that's the way I
thought of it my whole life was
my interest is in making something great
greatness lasting greatness Timeless and
I came to realize recently it's all an
offering to God and if you're making an
offering to God you're not thinking
about oh what's the budget or I hope I
hope these this segment of the audience
is gonna like it we don't we don't think
like that it's a higher vibration
we're making the best we can make to the
best of our ability
out of love and devotion that's what it
is and there is no
I'm changing it for someone else because
it can't be better than this devotional
act that we're doing
there is no higher no higher form